joining me now is the attorney general
of minnesota keith ellison
keith thanks so much for coming on the
show the secretary of state is now
challenging it's not challenging this
ruling what does that mean for voters
what's your message to them with four
days left in the race
my message is vote as early as you can
or vote on election day
uh my message is that we are going to
stand up
and make sure that every single ballot
is counted
at this point the eighth circuit has
ruled
that the ballots must be segregated if
they arrive
after 8 pm on election night
uh and but but we believe those votes
will be counted
and should be counted and must be
counted uh and we will litigate uh to
make sure that they
are counted uh at this point uh a
appealing to the supreme court would
mean going to a new supreme court with a
new justice
and uh that would mean that it would be
very difficult to predict what the
outcome would be
so what we've decided to do is make sure
the vote gets out and prepared ourselves
to litigate to make sure every vote is
in fact counted which we are absolutely
committed to
so how long do you expect the count to
take in minnesota do you anticipate
any challenges to those mainland votes
that the state is being forced to set
aside do you think you can get the count
done
fast how long well let me just say when
you say set aside
you're technically right but i want
people listening to realize
they're going to be counted but then
sequestered uh
and i expect that we're going to count
very quickly uh but i
to predict honestly neddy i don't i
don't want to raise expectations because
i really don't know
the fact is they're going to be counting
as fast as we can and uh
every vote will be counted that's my
that's my pledging commitment
and the secretary of state steve simon
is committed to the same thing
it isn't just the timing of the vote
that's causing legal issues there's also
how people vote just today an emergency
appeal was filed
with the u.s supreme court challenging
minnesota's mask mandate
at polling places do you expect that
masks will be enforced on tuesday given
we're in the midst of a pandemic
we are going to stand up for the health
and safety of a minnesotans period full
stop
anybody who's an anti-massacre is a
person fighting for the right to spread
a deadly virus this is extremely
irresponsible
and i cannot possibly imagine how that
is going to be a successful
in court i'll tell you this we are
fighting to save lives
we're citing fighting to protect health
and we're not going to stand by and let
people spread covet
the mass mandate is a legitimate
reasonable
measure to protect minnesotans lives in
a spiking environment
and um so there again uh we're going to
stand up
and fight for people's health and we're
not gonna back down
it's amazing that you have to fight for
people's health that's what america has
come to in 2020.
uh this month the washington post
reported a private security company is
recruiting
armed guards to watch polling places in
states like yours in minnesota
they've since backed down in minnesota
but you did call it
welcome you promised to combat any kind
of voter intimidation
there are militias in plenty of states
all gearing up for election day how do
you plan to do that to stop
voter intimidation in minnesota well the
way we've been doing it is if we find
out that they plan on
uh having guards at any polling place we
contact them we investigate them
we tell them it is illegal and we will
sue them if we need to
it's not permitted don't do it just let
people vote un unintimidated
uh people have a right to cast a ballot
and we don't need
and nor have we asked for the assistance
of groups like aegis
atlas and they have uh very responsibly
agreed not to do it
so we expect them to keep their word and
and we want every other group
to follow aegis atlas example and not
try to
interfere with the with the voting on
tuesday or before
so talking of interfering in the voting
there's also the interference from on
high
if comes if come tuesday night trump
decides to declare victory
and refuses to wait on states like
minnesota to finish counting
what do you and your fellow democratic
attorneys general plan to do
have you all been strategizing with each
other is there going to be a common
front is there a plan
we will be in court uh and the people of
the united states can
can bet that uh uh the ags who believe
in
free and fair elections will be
challenging any effort
to uh interfere with the count and the
and the vote
uh that we have been working together we
intend to but i want to be clear
uh we're not trying to tell people which
way to vote you can vote with any way
you want
but we're we're going to make sure that
people have their right to vote and that
their vote is counted
no matter who tries to interfere it up
and including donald trump
switching gears attorney general to the
other big story of this year
police violence and protests against
racism four officers have been charged
in the death of george
george floyd which kicked off everything
including one for murder but time and
again we've seen
black men and women be killed by police
who are then never brought to justice
how do you intend in minnesota to ensure
justice in this case
and avoid another brianna taylor
situation where no one was held
accountable for her death
well um we have charged four officers
who we believe
there's probable cause to believe that
uh they
they should be charged with
second-degree murder and uh
manslaughter the defense attorneys filed
a motion to dismiss
and the court ruled that there was
probable cause
for these cases to be bound over for
trial which is set
on march 8. that case is proceeding to
trial
we expect that there will be a robust
defense
but on the prosecution side we will
present
fairly clearly to the jury that we
the evidence we believe supports the
charges and then the jury will decide
12 fair-minded minnesotans hopefully
from hennepin county will
will make that decision and we're but
our job as prosecutors
is to present the evidence fairly and we
will do that
um and more than that many i can't say
because
i don't want anybody to prejudge the
facts in this case
we're trying the case to the jury not in
the public court of public opinion
well one case which has kind of caused a
lot of controversy
in kentucky i mentioned brianna taylor
do you think your republican counterpart
in kentucky
daniel cameron the ag there handled the
briana taylor situation to the best of
his ability because a grand juror
accused him of using the grand jury as a
shield to avoid accountability as they
weren't even given the option
to consider homicide charges in that
case
well when you ask me if peace handle it
to the best of his ability
i would have to know what his ability is
and i don't know
so what i'll say is that from a distance
not having all the facts um i was a
little bit
surprised uh and disappointed beyond
that i'm just gonna withhold judgment
okay just on the wider issue bill barr
the attorney general of the united
states did announce a civil rights probe
into george ford's death
but according to the new york times
barr's doj quietly ended its
investigation into the tamiya rice case
last year
didn't even didn't even tell the family
it also closed its eric garner case with
no charges last year
do you have any faith or confidence in
a.g bill barr
when it comes to getting justice for
black victims of police violence
well let me answer it this way our local
u.s attorney
has been a cooperative partner and i
want to commend her
she's been attending she's been helpful
her name's erica mcdonald
i have no complaints nationally you know
the jury is very much out i mean
look the obama administration had a
number of consent decrees
trying to bring reform to a number of
police departments
and jeff sessions and then bill barr
have not
uh have dropped those uh and not have
brought him not brought any
and there still is a number of problems
the federal government could be a much
more helpful partner and i wish they
would step
up and help bring reform through the
consent decree pattern and practice
lawsuit
but until this point they really have
not done so i can't complain locally
nationally you look at states like
illinois and chicago
kwame uh raoul who's the ag there is
fighting
to make sure that he can pick up where
the federal government has left
off and i just think that and also some
of the things the president has said
about police violence
uh have not been very unhelpful so you
know we'll see you know
bottom line is we need the federal
government to be a partner
um local authorities in minnesota have
been helpful nationally
jury's very much out on that
back in 2015 you famously predicted the
rise of donald trump
and you were laughed at live on national
tv have a listen
i remember
anybody uh well from the democratic side
of the fence who
who uh thinks that who's terrified of
the possibility of
president trump better vote better get
active better get involved because
this man has got some momentum and we
better be ready for the fact that he
might be leading the republican ticket
i know you don't believe that but i want
to go on
george we had jesse ventura in minnesota
win the governorship
nobody thought he was going to win i'm
telling you stranger things have
happened
um the polls uh a memorable clip there
the polls suggest
joe biden is on course for a big win are
we in danger of underestimating donald
trump once again
yes uh i do think that the democrats are
much
better positioned this year and i think
the efforts of the on the ground
activists have been
very very helpful and they've been
robust and out there working hard
but you know i think there's a lot of
people who don't
report that they're gonna vote for trump
and they and they are
so i think the most important thing to
do is to continue
to organize to get people to vote to get
people to the polls
i can tell you this the confidence level
of the republicans and trump
is a lot lower than it was last time i
don't think they expected to win last
time
but they were more hopeful and they were
more insurgent now they're running
scared and they're acting
as if uh they're desperate which is why
they're doing all this voter suppression
stuff
but i think that in a lot of states
where you know it could be it's going to
be tighter than people
expect so i think people better keep
working folks if you want to see joe
biden and kamala harris
running the country you need to work
very hard
right through to 8 pm on tuesday
keith just moments ago donald trump
speaking in rochester minnesota
addressed you directly i believe let's
have a listen to the clip
when large numbers of rioters and
vandals sack
the city of minneapolis earlier this
year keith ellison
did not ask them to submit a permit
he told the throngs of violent
demonstrators
by all means exercise your first
amendment rights right he said that
prior to them ripping down your city
keith ellison sided with flag-burning
extremists over law-abiding americans
he treats you like second-class citizens
he believes that the pro-american voters
have fewer rights than anti-american
demonstrators
keith ellison and joe biden want to
imprison you
in your homes while letting anarchists
agitators and vandals roam free
as they destroy your cities and states
do you want to respond to that i'm sure
you do
it's simply not true we've taken over 70
enforcement actions to try to get people
to comply
uh with the covet restrictions on the
left the political right
all of the political spectrum this is
not a political thing for us we are
simply trying to save people's lives
including his and everybody who was at
that rally so
he's uh putting out a false narrative
there and i'm very
sad he's doing it but i think most
people know given that we've looking at
over 230
000 people dead that uh we're we're
doing the right thing
and uh and i i'm confident that trying
to protect people is the right thing to
do and we're going to continue to do it
and um that's just that's just where
it's going to be
uh we're out of time we're out of time
keith that is about one last quick
question
when he comes to minnesota and attacks
you and ilhan omar both
of you black muslims how much of that do
you think is driven by racism or
islamophobia
i think he's demonstrated that he
does not have
i think the trump the president's a
racist sorry i just
that's just what i think and i i think
he's proven it any number of ways
but that doesn't change the fact that i
want to protect him from covet and
everybody else
and i wish he would just abide by the
restrictions
attorney general keith ellison thank you
so much for your time safe journey home
thanks for stopping to speak to us